[Music]
first things first are what happened no
I'm like trying to cover it but I'm like
you know what I might as well just show
less ya know Joey T what happened well
you did post on Instagram I did you know
I don't know why I'm so accident they
were doing this lift by partner and I
and we were trying something new which
is like I don't know why we're even
trying anything new you're spinning
really fast and then we butt heads and
all of a sudden by the way I can't stand
by look I hurt and I was like thank God
it wasn't my nose because I would be
right now getting a new nose as we speak
and then I go to the mirror and it was
just like blood running down my face and
of course I'm just so stupid and I'm
like oh how deep is it cuz everyone's
like stitches and I'm like I refuse to
get stitches I don't want stitches on my
face we have to go to Japan on Tuesday
and so this is what's been happening
Cheryl Burke giving et an update on her
head injury as she preps for her love on
the floor tour it kicks off as a
residency in Japan this summer before
coming to the u.s. in the fall okay so
you have the u.s. tour goes 30 cities
leave it goes into November because does
that mean no Dancing with the Stars for
you unless they want to just give me an
amazing dance partner that will travel
the United States today and I just show
up on Mondays and you don't actually
have a show every single Monday but I
don't think it's possible no I really
don't listen if they want to like have
two pros helping would you do see
yourself going back at home in some
capacity absolutely for sure yes Cheryl
wouldn't rule out returning to the
ballroom in a different capacity like on
the just announced Dancing with the
Stars
Junior yeah I would love to be a judge
of hosts cool idea yeah especially
coming from Dance Moms
I understand how these kids work we met
I caught that or host you heard that
good on me baby hold on there you go Oh
like this welcome to Dancing with the
Stars juniors you're in for a freaking
treat guys
[Music]
you